hello everyone you've seen the first
game I've played over the weekend this
is the second game and as you've seen in
that first game I really played
passively and my opponent punished me
severely
so this game I didn't prepare for this
game either but I did have a better good
night's sleep and I definitely decided I
will play more actively this game so I
found an old photo I thought you might
enjoy this is a my this is me and my
chess club colleagues some I think it's
some seven years ago when we want the
Croatian third league that's from the
left that's me you can see there then
you have young almighty you know young
you've seen him plenty of times on my
channel third is Slovak Omar teach
that's your sorrows dead fourth is
Miriam Melani candidate master also from
my hometown my opponent in this game
fifth me shoulder to sea and the sixth
is Professor Marion Garrett she also
seen my game against him played in the
my chess club championship so yeah
that's basically it I didn't really
prepare but I definitely decided to play
more actively and I have the black
pieces again because I skipped one game
so I only played two games he opened
with the d4 I played Knight to f6
he played Knight to f3 I played the g6
we have c4 and Bishop to g7 so the Kings
Indian defense here he went for Knight
to c3 and I decided to go d5 to
transpose into the groom felt he doesn't
go for the main line he plays III I
Castle and he goes for Queen to b3 this
is the Vienna variation of the groom
felled and I know some people play this
by capturing and c4 but I don't like
this style for black usually I prefer c6
or e6 I play D six here of course
because my plan was to push c5 he played
Bishop to d3 and now I played c5 I
didn't I didn't want to play passively
like the previous game so here I decided
to give up upon just to gain more
control in the center
he played C captors on d5 ad characters
and IVA and he played C cap
D captures and c5 as he does have to do
something I'm threatening c-4 so he
grabbed the pawn and I played Knight to
c6 so he's up a pawn but I have decent
development and you know more control in
the center so he castled and I played
rook to e8 I still didn't really figure
out a way how to develop my light square
bishop as I can't really move it his
attacking might be 7 pawn and I didn't
really like rook to b8 as you know this
a pawn can always go forward and Bishop
f4 will simply force my rook back so
that's still a thing to consider here
he probably should have played rook to
d1 continue developing pieces but he
decided to take advantage of this pin so
he played the Bishop to b5 and although
this is a fine move
maybe not moving the same piece twice in
the opening and Bishop to b5 will always
be an idea but okay Bishop to b5 and
here I went into a really deep think
because now that he played Bishop to be
if I was actually very happy to see this
move as now my b7 point is no longer a
threat so I can develop my light-square
bishop so here I really spent a lot of
time calculating maybe even like 25
minutes can't really remember exactly
how much time it was and I played Bishop
to a5 and I there were some ideas to
cover like maybe Knight to d4 trying to
attack my paint night but I can always
just capture it and attack his Queen and
b3 I will have time to deal with the
bishop attacking my rook but he played
rook to d1 now bringing a rope did you
open the file now having a triple attack
on my d5 pawn and I played Bishop to d4
protecting it and you know if if he
captures it I don't mind giving up the
light square bishop I will simply
improve the position of this night and I
didn't really think it was a worthy
worrying about the d5 pawn now so he
played Knight to d4 now he's attacking
that might be in peace and this was the
position I was considering when I played
that Bishop to a5 move here I played
Knight to g4 and it's a it's a very
complicated
because white has so many options for
example you have to you have to see that
if f3 is is is at all possible if black
plays f3 that which my opponent didn't
play I was definitely gonna go Queen to
h4 with threads of Queen to f2 Queen
characters on h2 and now after he
captures it I would have this Bishop to
e5 move and here I thought I I mean I
can't lose this game I can only play and
then you know either it'll win or draw
this game whatever he does
for example captures I can always
capture on on h2 if he doesn't capture
if plays g3 I can simply capture it with
the bishop so I didn't find anything
wrong with this for black and I thought
you know either I will create something
or you know I'll just be able to draw at
least and another thing is after this
Knight to g4 move I move I didn't even
consider was h3 I did consider it for
for a little bit but I thought that
grace just too many holes I can always
go Queen h4 Knight captures on f2 but h3
was actually the best move for white
here but I didn't consider it and after
the game he said he didn't consider it
either but after the game he thought
about he said to me what if I played h3
at the moment you played Knight g4 and I
said I haven't even like really given
that much thought but after after h3 I
would definitely have to go for Knight
captures and for kink after screen
captures on h4 Queen to h4 check and
then what could happen I don't know I
didn't calculate this line thoroughly
but I saw that I would have this Bishop
captures and the knight capture son d4
if he will if he wants to capture with
the rook after capturing good night then
rook to e1 will definitely be an idea
always but unfortunately this would
definitely go his favor if he decided to
go for this but after Knight to g4 he
played Knight captures on e4 and now I
played Knight captures on d4 first
eliminating this Knight now his queen is
attacked his Bishop is attacked so he
does have to capture the night he plays
chandi for and now I played rock
characters here and here again you have
to you have to consider the move f3 what
to do is f3 is played f3 is again the
best move for white as here I would I
would definitely have to think about a
lot of things but I played this rook
captures an e4 like really quickly and I
was I was really confident about this
move so he didn't he didn't even
consider seriously playing f3 what after
f3 you know there's there's a white
black does have some counter play but if
white really defends properly then then
white should be better in the end but he
didn't like the fact that his rooks were
still not connected for example even if
he pushes then if he pushes f3 then he
has to consider a lot of things can I
capture on d4 would check if he captures
with rogdon is rook to e1 a problem
queen is coming to h4 a lot of things to
consider here so he thought he can play
Bishop to e3 now defending his d4 pawn
and now f3 is still a threat but now I
know it's a different story now I played
Queen captures on h4 now f3 is no longer
possible because Queen captures on h2 is
a threat
he played h3 and here he missed my idea
and this was also my idea so I played
rook captures on e3 now I'm attacking
his Queen and he does have to capture
the rope so he played F captures on e3
and our played Queen to f2 check he
played King to h1 only move and now I
played Knight captures on e3 I'm
attacking his rock on d1 also
threatening checkmate on g2 and here he
played Bishop to f1 rook the g1 was also
possible if he played rook to g1 then I
can capture on d4 so now the material is
fine for me I'm up I'm up a pawn but he
still has to do something he would
definitely have to he would definitely
have to give up at least at least the
exchange so after Knight captures rook
captures I can capture the other pawn
and being two points up I mean this was
the best I could hope for you know out
of that position bringing up two points
in the end game but after this night
captures on III he played Bishop to f1
for some reason although I did consider
Bishop to f1 but I thought Rock to g1
was was a bit better
he played Bishop to f1 and how I played
Knight character some d1 rook captures
and D 1 and now Bishop cab for some d4
so this now Bishop captures on d4 comes
with a great temple because now again
I'm threatening Queen to g1 checkmate
because the bishop is now blocking
rogues defense of the g1 but ok he plays
a Bishop to b5 this is a very nice move
now there is no longer the threat of
checkmate the rook can come to f1 the
bishop is preventing my rook took from
coming to 8 so it's not that easy to
develop I played rock to d8 here Rock to
d8 because of course he was threatening
to capture my pawn here and now rope to
f1 is definitely a possibility I would
be I would have to capture the pawn on
b2 but he decided to go for c6 see six
week I dia of grabbing the b-pawn and
also the d5 pawn as he would attacked it
with the bishop I played B characters he
played Bishop captures now attacking my
pawn and here I was really really low on
the clock I had like 5 minutes but you
know I'm always slow on the clock
because I I like to calculate and I try
to calculate a lot of variations so
usually it will eat up most of my time
and the time controls were you know
decent classical time controls hour and
a half per player plus 30 seconds
increment per move so here there was no
real way to defend this nor nor did I
want to defend this I played King to g7
I would the idea that if he captures he
no longer has any Bishop captures on f7
with check radius and another thing I
saw that if he captures then he allows
me to play rook to e8
but here he thought that this wasn't the
problem he played Bishop captures
now the material is equal there are
opposite colored bishops so it seems
like a drawn endgame
if he can exchange Queens but not really
here I played the only move that
actually allows black to keep the
advantage I played rook to e8 with the
threat of rook to e1 and here he made a
move that lost in the game I was
expecting Queen to b4 this is the
strongest idea simply guarding e1 but
even here I can simply capture on b2 and
after he solidifies let's say Bishop to
b3 now I did have a clear plan of what
to do here the idea is you have to bring
the rook to e3 while your Bishop is on
f6 or anywhere on this diagonal the
Queen can't harass your king at g7 so
it's really only black that can do
something here because what's the big
difference in this position the material
is equal both players have Queens both
players have one rook and one bishop but
as you can see I have pawns on light
squares and I have a dark square bishop
so this is a really safe position for my
King and if you look at his position he
has a light square bishop but he has
pawns on light squares so he has like he
has only holes and dark squares and
that's a general rule when you were
playing with the with the opposite
colored bishops the the player that that
is attacked
it's like he's down a piece because his
bishop cannot help defending against my
dark square bishop and it's definitely
wide it's on the attack
so here the plan would be after he makes
some move let's say queen a5 he has to
do something
rook to e3 this is this was the main
idea and after after this the plan is
clear the plan is Bishop to e5 do I D h2
square and then white is simply lost
for example whatever white plays let's
say a for now I have Bishop to e5 and
now there is no move white can play if
he tries something like Queen d2 to
exchange Queens I simply play Queen to
g3 threatening checkmate and if he moves
now I simply capture it rook captures an
f3 but
it's only one point of this move rook to
e3 another idea is if he lets he moves
the bishop
simply not to allow me to capture it
with this area then I think simply play
rook captures on h3 the rogue has to be
captured and now I have Queen Queen to
h2 checkmate
but after I play this rook to e8 he
didn't go for a Queen to b4 he
immediately played Queen to d3
pressuring my bishop here but now this
is a big blunder as now I have a forced
checkmate in seven moves so it's it's
not a very complicated one feel free to
pause the video and find it I'm probably
my opponent so this variation but he
missed one move at the end of the
variation that's why maybe he played
Queen to d3 so I will give a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to find it congratulations
I mean I'm not gonna say her a great
player because I played this game as
it's not a very difficult one here rook
to e1 was played he captured I captured
he played King to h2 now comes Bishop to
g1 this was the key idea as now the King
cannot escape which came to g3 and it
was in this position that my opponent
resigned King to h1 is forced now I
would play Bishop to f2 this comes with
a discovered check also blocking the
King from reaching g3 he'd have to move
and Queen to g1 is checkmate so yeah
after Bishop to g1 check he resigned the
game and I wasn't very impressed by this
game I played as I didn't play the most
precise moves but I was I was glad it
was an interesting game and I didn't
play passively so you know one day when
I improved my openings and maybe maybe
maybe are able to reach move 15 with a
decent position then I will be able
maybe to play actively from a decent
position but now that as I don't prepare
for games and I don't really have a
great knowledge of openings it's very
hard very hard to play but yeah I played
against the Mari underlining a lot of
times and you know sometimes I went
something
he wins but as he is a better positional
player I always have to try some active
ideas against him sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't
this time it worked so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it so yeah as
usual you can check to my previous video
see her thank you for watching and I
will see you soon next video is towel
vs. both mini game one of their World
Chess Championship match hopefully I can
I can finish that before the 2018
candidates start so yeah thank you all
and I will see you soon